hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sally welt ich
stehe heute nicht in meiner küche aber
ich habe heute trotzdem ein rezept video
für euch und zwar bin ich gerade in
graben-neudorf denn heute hat meine
beste freundin nadja geheiratet
daniel und wir stehen hier gerade vor
der hochzeits location und vorhin war
schon die kirchliche trauung und ich
habe natürlich die hochzeitstorte für
die natur gemacht
so komme ich später und zeigt euch jetzt
einfach nur ein paar bilder von der
trauung
wow
weihnachten fällt
oder hat es oft scheuen
hat das zeug zum verein blicke vertrauen
weil wir den super schön unsere
emotional und trauzeugin von der natur
und zwar wirklich super schild muss ich
eine wunderschöne frau und ich habe
jetzt eine hochzeitstorte gemacht und
zwar ist eine eistorte drei strecke und
ich einfach mal wie ich sie zubereitet
habe was ich zu hause vorbereitet habe
und nehme ich jetzt in meiner haut
ich werde jetzt die hochzeitstorte zu
bereiten und zwar habe ich jetzt schon
ein bisschen was vorbereitet
ich habe bereits die wiener böten
gebacken in 20 26 und 32 cm größe und
die kann man auch gut vorbereiten und
durchschneiden und einfrieren zum
beispiel wenn man nicht so viel platz in
der küche und im kühlschrank hat jetzt
kommt das café an die reihe und zwar
habe ich mich für ein 40 parfait
entschieden mit der das mango weil auch
das thema der hochzeit und bisschen
aprikose und 40 ist und ich denke es
passt geschmacklichen farblich auf jeden
fall super mit dazu ich mache jetzt
dieses 40 ps nur für die 26 hat orte und
wenn dann später die zwei weiteren
einfach nur so führen und zeigt euch mal
die zutaten für das café brauche ich 30
gramm magazine 300 milliliter 40 auf 304
sicher eine mango sieben eier und sieben
eigelbe etwa 200 gramm zucker 300 gramm
joghurt und 500 milliliter sahne
ich nehme jetzt zuerst nämlich denn
zuerst erst die eier und eigelb habe ich
aber auch so ein paar für meine andere
pfade zubereitet da habe ich zimt und
ein vanille kaffee grund jetzt kommen
die eier in die röhre schüssel gemeinsam
mit den eigens beim zucker müsste jetzt
natürlich auch ein bisschen nach
geschmack arbeiten
ich habe auch noch für sich und für sich
saft also ich gehe jetzt mal nicht den
kompletten zucker mit rein denn man kann
ja noch abschmecken aber man muss immer
darauf achten dass das eis wenn es
gefroren ist bisschen an süße verliert
also schmeckt dann nicht mehr so süß wie
die grundmasse deswegen durch ein
bisschen süßer lassen und jetzt ruhig
dass auf höchster stufe bei 80 grad
und zwar fünf minuten lang und falls ihr
das jetzt im wasserbad macht könnt ihr
einfach ein wasserbad aufstellen
aufkochen lassen und der zweite drauf
geben und dann eben fünf minuten auf
höchster stufe rühren und er hat es eben
auch ungefähr 8
um
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal die sahne steif schlagen und die
dann in den kühlschrank stellen
und auch die aktie mit dem 40 saft
verrühren und zwei minuten auf höchster
stufe sprudelnd kochen lassen
nach hinten nur stelle jetzt die hitze
aus und lassen die höchste stufe kalt
schlagen bis die etwa 25 grad erreicht
hat und in der zwischenzeit kann wird
auch schon mal die flüssige schälen
heute und auch den mango klein schneiden
und falls jetzt nicht mit der
küchenmaschine ist sondern mit dem
wasserrad arbeitet nehmt ihr jetzt den
topf vom wasserbad herunter also die
schüssel mit den gelben und können sie
jetzt einfach mit dem handrührgerät hart
schlagen
ich habe jetzt hier bereits 300 gramm
jeweils vom 40 und von der mango
abgemessen das gerät also die
küchenmaschine gold ist auch noch ein
bisschen weiter bis wir die 25 grad
erreicht haben
und wer möchte kann jetzt hier einfach
nur ein bisschen zitronensaft einrühren
denn das sorgt einfach dafür dass der
süße geschmack auch ein bisschen
ausgeglichen wird
die einmischung hatte etwa 25 grad
angenommen also ein paar grad mehr oder
weniger das nicht schlimm
jetzt kann ich die akad jetzt ein
bisschen abgekühlt ist
schon mit der frucht mischung verhören
erstmal ein bisschen und dann den rest
aber können natürlich auch dieses hoch
pury mit dem saft und mit der akademie
zusammen zwei minuten aufkochen lassen
also so können das natürlich auch machen
und dann einfach direkt im topf das
pürieren und dann spart ihr euch hier
eine schüssel dann nehme ich jetzt die
eier mischung und da können jetzt auch
ein teil mich zum fruchtpüree damit die
gleiche temperatur annimmt dass jetzt
auch kurz unter regeln
jetzt werden wir einfach nur noch alle
zutaten verbunden
die reihenfolge ist nicht ganz egal also
die sahne wird es trotzdem zum schluss
untergehoben damit einfach die machen
doch trotzdem schön locker bleibt so
jetzt um diese masse aus dem topf wieder
zurück in den großen topf zur restlichen
eier masse
sorgfältig unterheben
und jetzt noch die sahne unterheben
jetzt die partie vorbereitet und ich
kann die torte damit gefüllt und zwar
bis jetzt hier bereits den ersten
tortenboden auf einem stück backpapier
und darunter ist ein trottel retter als
er braucht einfach mit platte printer
und das sind jetzt die böden die schon
eingefroren hat das heißt sie sind auch
schön kalt und ja bis vier böden und
werde jetzt dementsprechend dreimal
füllung rein machen und habe jetzt die
füllung auch schon abgemessen
und wer jetzt immer ein drittel davon
nehmen bei mir sind es jetzt immer 700
gramm
er guckt dann einfach wenn ihr bisschen
weniger nehmen wollt nehmt weniger und
den rest des pakets könnte er einfach so
einfrieren
jetzt kommt der zweite tag drauf
jetzt stelle ich das erst mal kurz ins
gefrierfach und zwar für etwa eine halbe
stunde bis die macher ein bisschen fest
ist und dann kommen auch die restlichen
schichten mit rein
jetzt kommt noch der teig deckel drauf
das führt man sage das paar
und jetzt muss die torte abgedeckt
werden und eingefroren werden für
mindestens 24 stunden
ich werde jetzt erst mal eine stunde so
einfrieren und dann erst abdecken
dann bin ich auch sicher dass ich nichts
runter drücken und dann wie gesagt 24
stunden einfrieren und so werde ich
jetzt auch die anderen zwei befüllen und
dann werde ich sehen
am tag der hochzeit erste kugel
die tat bereits über nacht eingefroren
und ich habs jetzt bereits aus dem
tortenring gelöst und ich möchte so eine
vintage torte das heißt ich bestreite
torte jetzt noch ein bisschen mit einer
samenmischung man kann sich natürlich
auch so lassen also ich finde sie jetzt
zurück hier richtig schön aber dadurch
dass hier dieser mittlere boden etwas
kleiner war statt der tortenboden
verschwunden
was aber absolut nicht schlimm ist als
ich finde es fast super zur torte und
jetzt habe ich seine mit mascarpone und
etwas sonderbar aufgeschlagen und es
streiche ich jetzt einmal komplett auf
die torte und dann friere ich sie eben
wieder ein bis zur hochzeit morgen
hier habe ich jetzt die torten und zwar
habe ich jetzt jeweils eine torte in
seiner transportbox transportiert weil
wir haben jetzt grad 30 grad
wahrscheinlich und es ist eine eistorte
aber selbst bei ganz normalen torten
jetzt keine austrocknen empfiehlt es
sich einfach eine transportbox zu nehmen
die sie jetzt aus styropor und halten
eben auch die kälte drinnen und ich
zeige euch drinnen mal ganz kurz wie es
innen drin aussieht
typisch moratti winkel einfach in den
kofferraum steht bei 30 grad in der
sonne
diese sieht so aus also ich habe immer
eine torte po box drin einfach dafür
beim transport auf sicher sind und hier
habe ich das jetzt so viel torte einfach
nicht wissen frischhaltefolie eingepackt
das inet rutscht oder ihr könnt aber
auch zum beispiel beim transport einfach
mit silikon matte darunter legen
und hier sind orten retter oder eine
tortenplatte nehmen jetzt kann ich die
torten alle aus wacken und wieder
zusammensetzen so angekommen in dieser
wundervollen küche in meinem team sind
versuchslabor egal ich habe hier alles
vorbereitet übrigens am transport bei
den zwei großen torten immer so ein
tortenring außen rum dann geht einfach
auch wenn mal die torte verrutschen
sollte nichts kaputt damit die torten
rausgeholt sieht gar die vorspeise
gerichtet und ich muss jetzt natürlich
ein bisschen aus vorbereiten und zwar
kommen ja die torten gleich auf diesen
torten ständer und in der mitte ist
dieser starb das heißt ich muss jetzt in
der mitte von jeder torte an loch
ausstanzen kann mich dann dieser starb
durch passen kann der eben die torten
blase zusammenhält und damit jetzt die
mitte finde werde ich jetzt einfach so 2
gegen schöne drauflegen habe diese traf
dabei aber kein lineal zum beispiel
nehmen
lege ich drüber und dann markiere ich
die mitte
dann war hier ein ausstecher mir dabei
immer können natürlich auch einfach ein
ganz normaler ausstecher nehmen aber da
hatte ich auch ein bisschen hoch war
leider nicht so hoch wie eine torte aber
es wird hoffentlich trotzdem passen
erzählt bisschen in warmes wasser weil
sie eine eistorte ist an soll es ein
bisschen einfacher gehen jetzt drauf
legen noch mal am besten kontrollieren
da gibt es kein zurück mehr und dann
versuchen durch zu bohren so und dann am
besten stückchenweise immer ein bisschen
was rausholen so wie jetzt hier
das ausstechen ist sehr schwierig dass
er eine eistorte ist aber ich finde ich
die szene wenn ich eine idee hätte und
frage ich ziehe ein apfel im kern und
jetzt habe ich die form schon vor
bestand sind jetzt einfach immer kleine
stücke heraus so wie hier
und die stücke vom kameramann stücke
kontrolle ist natürlich ob das starb
auch durchgehend bis zum boden und durch
kann ich die torte schon mal auf die
mittlere tortenplatte setzen
ich habe lange einen schotten retter
darunter also geht es auch ganz gut
damit die torten erst mal drauf gesetzt
und jetzt mache ich hier fordern noch
mal ein kleines loch rein und zwar hier
so kleine röhrchen und da kann ich dann
noch wasser einfüllen und hier noch
blumen reinstecken und so hat einfach
die blume kein kontakt zur torte war es
natürlich sehr wichtig hier schweizer
zeit keine es war und blumen sind
jetzt kommt da das röhrchen rein und
falls es doch zu groß ist kann mit creme
auffüllen oder einfach von den kuchen
rest steckt jetzt setzt sich die torte
zusammen zuerst kommt natürlich die
größte torte dann kommt wie gesagt
dieses zwischen element und es wird
jetzt ist rein gedreht diesen übergang
hier das sieht man später gerne lasse
man muss es ja ein bisschen größer
ausstellen hat muss ein bisschen
einfacher bei der mittleren etage schaue
ich jetzt dass das röhrchen für die
blumen einfach so ein bisschen versetzt
zu der unteren ist
unglaublich dass ich gerade mal das
hochzeitsauto zu verhelfen
jetzt kommt die oberste platte und das
muss jetzt mit einer schraube befestigt
werden
schraubendreher mich natürlich nicht am
ball aber ich nehme einfach die palette
tut auch jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen glatt streichen und ausgleichen
und jetzt dekoriert die torte fertig ich
hätte nämlich die blumen
falls ihr die tour jetzt noch länger
stehen lassen müsst ihr natürlich die
röhrchen jetzt mit wasser füllen aber
bei uns wird sie gleich gegessen
deswegen kann ich jetzt auf das wasser
verzichten jetzt einfach da wo ihr sie
hinhaben ich habe jetzt für da oben
einfach die blumen mit etwas trat
zusammen gewickelt und kann sie dann
gebündelt reinstecken
jetzt habe ich hier noch eine hochzeit
figur und zwar hatte ich mehrere zur
auswahl und habe mich dann doch für
diese entschieden denn ich finde dass
die einfach ja so thematischen optisch
ganz gut dazu fast 1000 ich übrigens ein
kleines loch ich weiß nicht wofür es da
ist wahrscheinlich es von der produktion
aber ich bin uns das loch jetzt zum
befestigen und zwar kompletten
schaschlikspieß rein dann kann ich
einfach ausschließen dass ist verrutscht
da oben gefällt es schwarz nicht so ganz
ich finde es passiert so deswegen
verdeck ich das jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen mit schleierkraut
so sieht jetzt die fertige torte aus als
sie mir gefällt sie sehr gut vor allem
dieser vintage style auch richtig schön
ich hoffe dass sie jetzt natürlich auch
dem brautpaar gefällt und dass sie auch
gut schmeckt und deswegen tragen wir
jetzt raus ich kann es nicht alleine
tragen so viel zu schwer
hk
wenn ich normal
in einer
mit
ich war
ich kenne
und lang allein
schlecht
hochzeit zu sanieren den rest habe ich
wieder eingepackt
ein stück auch gleich aufgeben und am
ersten tag auf essen jetzt musste zum 8
doch die ganze menge
ich werde es auch hier zu gehen zudem
eine firewall
natürlich sehr hoch
dann wünscht euch nochmal alles alles so
seine ganz viele tolle kinder damit ihr
mal aus warten
und auch nachher und unser wissen
die beiden bands lesen